white privilege you may not be aware if
you have it but you sure as hell know if
you don't white privilege refers to the
benefits white people get from society
that people of color don't it's walking
into a store and not being followed on
the suspicion you might steal it's
wearing baggy pants and a backwards hat
and not being labeled a gangsta and it's
not being harassed by the cops but what
does it mean to you what is white
privilege in my opinion I would say that
white privilege is a luxury that white
people have not being judged off Todd
you know it's probably subtle but with
what's happening lately is really that's
white privilege exists that's it what is
it it's the ability to have our kids
playing in a park and play with the toy
gun and not get shot do you think white
privilege exists
definitely it's basically a ticket to
anything that everybody else is excluded
do you think you benefit from that
absolutely
I can expect to be treated respectfully
and I can expect to be taken for Who I
am
without people thinking about my skin
color often it's here's how great it is
to be white I can get in a time machine
and go to it anytime and it would be and
also when I get there
that is exclusively a white privilege
you know I got called the n-word the
other day you know I couldn't really do
anything due to the fact that you know
if I did anything I may get shot by the
police so you know that's white
privilege you know some people can do
certain things that you know African
Americans really can't do what are some
other examples of white privilege that
you think you see in your day-to-day
life where white people might get
certain benefits from society that you
know you don't Thanks if you have that
pretty well you have okay credit my god
why can't you give me a chance to build
my great they give it to the white man
or the white women real quick why you
don't think that I want it there's a lot
that goes into it there's a lot that we
have that we take for granted and a lot
of it has to do with race we're just
gonna intellectually denigrate and scold
you for the abuse of your white
privilege what's white privilege if you
grew up white how do you think your life
might have been different
I probably have a better job than I have
now you know if I have a better
education probably have better
opportunities to get out the
neighborhood and have a chance you know
and not be like stereotype based on what
my parents do what would you do
differently if you were like I forget
money get paid it would be nice to just
walk around and not feel judged all the
time if my boyfriend and I could both
walk around and be white for a day
together like that would be amazing and
to not be called you know a nigger lover
or something like that if I was a white
dude for a day I wouldn't really run
into any issues during the daytime at
all like I just kind of walk around and
exist you should probably put like a
GoPro camera on an african-american male
have him walk around you'd have to be in
my shoes though to feel it
if I have recognition that my police
brutality will be fixed immediately and
how everything's been going like in
Ferguson I want to feel secure in my
community put in my work